his 9 times as an all defensive first
team member and an NBA Defensive Player
of the Year earned him the nickname of
the glove a nine time NBA all-star NBA
champion two-time Olympic gold medalist
and Basketball Hall of Famer and head
coach of the three-headed monsters that
are runner-up in the inaugural season of
the big three which returns with its
draft this week Gary Payton good to see
you good to see you too rich did I hit
most of that I think I mean you had well
you did a great job I like that 17
seasons in the NBA where you're from
originally Oakland Oakland California
Oakland California so did you grow up
dreaming a plan for the Warriors is that
what you do it's never never you know
what I didn't even dream of I'm thinking
about going to play basketball my father
made me play basketball really and did
my brother I've seen him and I start
watching him and then I said let me get
into it and I we had a tree outside in
front of our house I started planning I
started liking it then all of a sudden I
started you know going out for my team's
I start being pretty good and then wants
to start pretty pretty good I just kept
playing kept playing and then I got
better and better so do you have dreams
of playing for the Raiders in Oakland
Raiders never from a 49er fan big time
49 if everybody don't like me and open
because of that I don't care though you
know I really don't care so I'm a 49er
fan when the team leaves your city
mm-hmm and they're gonna leave again I
can't be a fan I can't be official when
they move to Los Angeles I think that it
was over for me I was a little bit with
them but now I'm really off of them now
it also helped to have Joe my time yeah
yeah and I had Jerry Rice I had Ronnie
live I had everybody well I had a lot of
teams Taylor do I receive or Roger Craig
I had a lot I had a lot of players on my
team and we want a lot championships we
got five number two now we're number two
look at you so you're still an honor fan
right now I got a season tickets for him
all the time you know every year I got
season tickets I'm right there on the
field I see them all I go right there in
a new state and the new stadium is not
for us we should have stated candles
should've kept Candlestick right there
we should have just built
the part right there because the cold
weather get a lot of the team they come
to Santa Clara now it's a it's a little
different we're not we're not good but
we got Jimmy Jimmy G now I think we're
gonna be okay I think we don't be
alright you're on the Jimmy G I'm Oh
Jimmy G man you could come in and win
five straight of football games we won
and ten then we finished six and ten
we're gonna be fine we're gonna be okay
I think Jimmy did he would I mean what
he did was really incredible I was
exciting that's why we get mad money
Oakland guy who's a liar guy okay giant
fan to San Francisco I'm D right there I
was at opening day we got beat down by
the Seattle Mariners but we you know
once I get back I'm going to see them
too I'm over there I liked it I like the
Giants to see you up do you have an
issue with the Warriors moving to San
Francisco then you know what they're
taking all our teams away from his
Oakland A's are gonna be the only team
that's gonna be left there yeah I mean
nowadays if you don't get a stadium and
you don't get a good one you're not
gonna you're not gonna get anything you
know you're not gonna do something so
they they took opportunity to go time
Cisco I'm not really I'm not on that
because I think that we're supporting
them very well in Oakland we wanted the
best arenas in Oakland I'm gonna see how
many people come from Oakland to commute
all the way over there that's gonna be a
traffic jam but you know I'm not gonna
go over there no more you know that's
not my area I think we're from Oakland
and then we should have stayed in
Oakland Gary Payton here in the Rich
Eisen show
so it's interesting last year with the
big three got back in key arena right
got back with you and Rashard Lewis
going into key arena yeah what was that
like for you to stroll in there it was
great you know they had had all my logos
on the floor upstairs everybody was
going crazy we're we're in the playoffs
we want a close game too to go into the
championship but it was great to see
them don't fans get basketball back whoo
weird the NBA is talking about getting
it back again and but the big three came
here and I like like Ice Cube for doing
that bringing it back to Seattle and
getting me and Rashard a narrative then
we went in the game you know all the
fans were going crazy it was just like
the old days when we were in there plan
for the Sonics everybody was
to the basketball de Waal basketball
back there and it was great yeah so I
and it can be supported you would
believe it we can be supporting the
NHL's already knocking on seattle story
well we already got it
saturday we got it we got a guy who's
gonna go and try to rebuild Key Arena
from the ground up we got that approved
so is now it's up to the NBA do the NBA
wants to expand or whatever they want to
do our hope that we do we got a great
commissioner and Adam silver and I think
he wants to I think he won he knows that
we we we are we got our team stolen from
us and and he wants us to be back in
Seattle because it's a good good market
their aunt Durant was chosen and
everything Danny if we de kept him we
had Westbrook the next year and look
what happened you know we wouldn't have
Oklahoma City we still had that team
that's rolling right there and it'll be
great for Gary Payton here on the Rich
Eisen show so I was mentioning when I
introduced you here that I was in the
old Boston Garden locker room the old
car yeah you had just beaten the Celtics
and I was covering it for NBA tonight on
espn2
so look what happened how did that work
out it's amazing how you know long it's
been to be honest with you know the
thing I'll never again forget because it
was the first assignment I ever had
outside of Sports Center as a wisecrack
and guy on on the set night like me me
you to say I was gonna say it what I may
have said about you or Carl or SRAM for
anybody in that room and I remember
walking in there thinking oh I hope I
didn't say anything stupid and it taught
me a lesson about how how to conduct
myself on here but I also remember that
you guys you just won 14 out of 15 was
that what we we determined Brock when we
looked at yeah that was the 14th win and
15 games and you were on fun but nobody
in that room was it was totally
businesslike to me it looked like you
guys were not either having fun or you
just took look looked at it it this was
a business trip well what was it like
for that team were you guys having fun
you know we rich people don't understand
that that team right there out of five
years in a row we wanted 60 games in a
row for six year for five or six years
in a row it was normal to us we had a
veteran team so
we were talking about winning
championships that was our focus it
wasn't a happy thing that we win 15 out
of 14 out of 15 games it was just normal
for us so it was business like so
everywhere we went we were we were
business like we wanted to win
basketball games and make statements and
you know that's where that's what our
mentality was and that's where it's a
little bit different because we're all
older we were all in our AVM perfect 12
year we had a lot of debtless shrimp we
had a lot of guys that was really really
veterans we didn't hahaha and all that
we were straight business we wanted to
win games and that's what we wanted to
do and we took it very serious mm-hmm
and how much George Karl is in you when
you're in the huddle
four big three you you uh you model you
know are you you know I am when you look
at coaches I did another play for some
greats you know I played for Lenny
Wilkens I don't play for Pat Riley I
don't play for Phil Jackson and then
Karl Malone is my mean car George Karl
is my favorite so George crawl is my
favorite so when you get them type of
three and I and I'd be coaching in a big
three I do the same I try to be a coach
players coach you know I let them do
what they want to their old you know if
they don't know how to play by now I'll
just sit them down and I'll sit them
down and I tell them what we want and
that's what what's so different about me
and this thing everybody try to take
this lead is okay these guys are old
they can't play they can't move but I
got a team where I I make them
accountable you come in here you be in
shape if you're not in shape I'm not
gonna pick you I'm not gonna put you on
the floor you won't be on my team anyway
and we we run through practices we do
drills we do you know we do practice and
these guys are in great shape and that's
why it worked last year because
everybody got in his shape and they made
it entertaining to people yeah
the MVP of the league Rashard Lewis your
captain Reggie Evans is back as a
co-captain well Mahmoud Abdul Rove now
now Ricci's everybody seen him at LSU
mm-hm and he's the same way he's just 49
years old now he's skinny
he can he's skinny he was coming off to
picking rose I had him in picking rose
last year and he were he was
he was just unstoppable his jump shot is
still the same he'll be here tomorrow
and he's gonna evaluate things and I'm
gonna get you know I'm gonna talk to him
and we take this serious and I think
he's in great shape for the be 49 years
old and stay in that type of SEC shape
best shooter you've ever seen with your
own to us Gary Payton that's your best
shooter oh that's a tough one you know
because I had Dell Ellis with me I MUC
move with me
Dell curry was a it was a good one you
know Steph Curry's dad
I even Glen Rice was a great shooter you
know so Reggie Miller I had a lot of
shooters that I can see but if I give it
to anybody
pure shooters who can come off picks I
have to give it to Dale Ellis I have to
pass one best one one shot to win the
game that's the guy that's the guy I'm
gonna give it to I think he's gonna
drill it every time Gary Payton here in
the Rich Eisen show we'll take a break
come back talk about the current game
who you think has the best chance to
knock off Golden State who you think the
MVP is and then obviously you've got a
son on the Lakers roster I want to know
what you think about all that okay and
again just so we take a break you do not
have any children in Lithuania right now
correct no children if I do please don't
tell me in 60 seconds with Kevin Garnett
still to come
[Music]
today's polls poll question which you
can vote on on our half as always which
you get by hitting the link at the top
of our twitter handle at Rich Eisen show
or anywhere on the Apple App Store or
Google Play Store it's brought to you by
the haunted dream garage spring event
the best place to leave winter in your
rear-view mirror you could get a great
deal on the versatile 2018 HRV right now
the Honda dream garage spring event is
happening at your local Honda dealer
Chris Brockman with gary payton sitting
here it's perfect time to unveil it go
for it let's do it who do you most want
to see in the NBA Finals Gary well Bron
James and the Cavaliers the Golden State
Warriors
you want to see them both for a fourth
straight year or neither new blood if
you had to choose one of those four you
want to see LeBron you want to see the
Warriors those are two choices you want
to see them both or neither
which one well you know what I'm always
in a new blood I want to see something
different
I think Toronto is a group basketball
team that you know they don't only want
to have a chance to beat in Cleveland to
me right now in the East you don't think
the Sixers the way their says well you
know what they're playing very very well
but their young team you haven't had
experience in the NBA like in the finals
like that on a seven-game series rich
you you got to understand you're not
gonna play somebody one time and then a
month later you're gonna see them you
got to see them every night you're gonna
make adjustments and I think LeBron is
very good at that plan in a seven-game
series
and plant very well he plays different
in the playoffs and I think it's gonna
be hard to beat him if he's got it
rolling and I think that team all they
gotta do is get two or three good games
together you get out three one it's hard
to come back oh no and and and I think
over there in the West people are
forgetting Golden State hasn't had these
injuries like always they always played
somebody who was injured and now they're
injured and let's see how I go Steph
Steph Curry is injured they don't know
when he's gonna come back and you got a
good team over there in Houston that
this is what they did they told you do
you remember that general rodiger told
you two years ago we're gonna gear up
for the Golden State Warriors and we're
gonna try to out shoot him
I'm gonna get shooters every time and
he's done a great job with that and I
think it's gonna be hard for them to
beat Houston
if Harding and and and CP and all em are
playing very well like they are so
you choose neither you'd like the either
I want to see some new blood rather I'd
rather see a Houston and a Toronto go at
it so let's get into this a little bit
deeper Gary Gary Payton here on the Rich
Eisen show how important is experience
in the playoffs I mean for real here
they're very important why is that
because you got to know the possession
game possessions gets shorter refereeing
gets a little bit better you know
they're gonna call a game tight you have
to be in a composure
state of mind you know you got to be in
that that when your veins have ice in it
gotta be in there and I think LeBron is
that type of guy and these guys who been
together a long time
have you seen the Golden State Warriors
for the last three years they play very
well in the playoffs because they become
one they become one team they start
playing defense they started to know
where everybody's got to be they're
helping their doing a lot of things and
I think that experience is like that
when you're in a game and it's 88-89
and you need one possession and you want
a veteran didn't understand and who's
gonna make that big shot I'd rather go
with some veterans instead of a young
team okay so when it all comes down to
it you think that teams like the Spurs
will advance because of that alone over
say somebody like New Orleans that
hasn't done it before I mean just just
taking a look at any of these matchups
that we see that are down the pike
Eastern Western Conference teams with
the experience will truly what a
coaching to got a good thing to do about
a - were pop-pop makes the right
decisions and the right right calls at
the right time right now with San
Antonio's roster I don't know if they
can match up with New Orleans you know
you got to know a roster that's gonna be
there - as you seen the other yesterday
what Ginobili did when he came in the
ballot ball game at the age of 40 you
know he took that team and got a win for
it yes that's because he's been arrested
he's got he's got a lot of experience he
knows the right play to make and he
willed San Antonio back last night and
made the guys be more comfortable image
and a rhythm shot what Tony Parker used
to do and i think so yeah i think a
veteran team can do that what do you
think's going on with Kawhi Leonard
there well you know what
we can do you know speculate about that
you just can't I know it's some problems
going on in there he doesn't want to
play for some reason it might have been
a mistake between whoever but right now
he's not happy I don't think he's happy
man he's showing that he's not happy
you know because if a guy is not happy
and he doesn't want to be there
then he doesn't want to play but if
you're ready and and I'm a competitor if
I get healthy I don't care what's
happening I'm gonna go play but it's
something there and and I hope they can
fix it I hope that he doesn't get
chopped off because that's not gonna be
good for San Antonio that's gonna be
your whole rebuilding process that's
they start that's one of the best
basketball players in the NBA and I
think they just need to work it out you
ever have a problem like that in your
career I did I did that's why I got
traded you know I I had that in 2003
with the new management and the
ownership and it didn't work out and you
know I actually be traded and and it
happened that way I thought I was gonna
be in Seattle the rest of my life career
but it didn't work out and you know
things do don't work out and that's what
happens so and then you wound up with
the Bucks and then with the Lakers
eventually what was that like on that
Lakers team I mean there's Carl there's
I mean there's so many out Fedor's in
that team with Kobe as well yeah Richard
like you know what when I got through
with the 13 years I was really
devastated by leaving the Seattle
SuperSonics
and I decided that my career was
completed it was a complete career so I
said I'm not gonna sign long deal
contracts I'm inside one year and I'm
gonna try to chase for for a ring and
when I came to LA it was a great
situation it was a great situation but a
lot of things happen you know Kobe got
into his little situation but it got me
closer to Kobe and become a big brother
to him and I got to know him very well
I think you've caught him along when
they got hurt remember when Carmelo got
hurt we were 18 and 3 we were rolling
they were talking about us beating that
the Chicago Bulls record and then all of
a sudden we went up and down and I'm the
only one who played 82 games out of the
big four and everybody else and we still
went to the finals
it just it was just not meant to be
that's it and now your kids playing for
the Lakers he is like for you to sit
there and
watch him on the active roster [ __ ] I'm
gonna be honest it's frustrating
sometimes because you'll be wanted your
son to do what you want him to do
because the way you play and it's not
fair to him thereon because he can't
match me
he might be named after me and it's the
same name but I don't put my son
accountable for what I think and because
I played on a high high level and I want
him to play on that same level but he
has to be Gary to second not Gary Payton
you know that's me I've done everything
I saw Ike it's only gonna be one me so
it's got to be him but you know what
makes me happy is that he have got to
this level and he's got there that's the
accomplishment of being there so he's
there and all I tell him now is I stay
off of him I'll just say you have to do
this you have to do that to make it in
this NBA and he's done a good job he's a
great young player he's a good little
talent and I think that he's gonna make
it in this NBA and I'm very happy for do
you have any demands of the Lakers to
take any more of your children none no
no I I don't care I got one in there I
got a young one that's gonna be okay but
nothing okay so I guess that's my that
was my left-handed way to talk about the
conversations with levar yeah I did you
know we were in a tunnel and we just
talked about it you know people rich I
played against levar in college he was
at Washington State and I was at Oregon
State did he get those two points
against you but you know what I don't
have any problem with him doing what he
do he marketing in himself that's where
he wants to do it I probably you know I
wouldn't do it that way you know and a
lot of people wouldn't do it the way
that he wants to do it and that's what
he do it but I will give him this he's
been successful with it because we're
talking about him you see what we're
doing now we're talking about him and
he's made a market and that's what it's
all about it's about being having a
market and you know he want to market
his kids and that's what he's doing you
know so but the kids got to understand
they gotta play you know they got to
play the game
how good is launcher really good he
really good people don't understand
right now rich he doesn't know how to
score and he's letting people you know
he's I think he's reading to me what I
can't shoot I can't do this if he goes
and work on his game this summer and
become a scorer and not a shooter
because he's not a shooter he's not a
shooter he can be a scorer and once he
gets that in his game because he's
almost like a Westbrook to me he can
rebound a basketball he has a great
vision a great great court vision he can
do that plays great defense to me he
just need to score he just needs us know
how to score and I think in two to three
years everybody not change your mind
about this kid because he can he can do
it well I mean I think the way that
people again view him is through his
dad's conversation right right right and
and I you know this year everybody
thought he would have a target on his
back I don't think that that
materialized at all I think a lot of
people actually in this league respect
his game a lot the only question is is
how will his dad's conversation since
he's gone to Lithuania he's removed
himself from what whatever has been
going on back and forth with the with
the Lakers before that he did have one
comment about Luke from Lithuania that
created a bit of a stink bomb here in
Los Angeles because of the way the
Lakers did not in a way respond directly
to it that's the question is how his
actions affect that locker room because
of what he's saying about his son's
treatment or other kids that need to be
taken by the Lakers Gary well I think
the Lakers have done a great job of
stopped acknowledging him let it go this
is this is Magic Johnson's team let him
run it and and that's what magics have
done he's led he's rented he said I
don't care what you say you you got your
you you have the right to have your
opinion you have your right to have your
opinion but I'm running this Laker team
and that's just the way it is it is what
it is I mean like I said if Lonzo comes
over and start playing and doing the
things he's supposed to you don't have
anything to say because he's gonna be on
the floor making and making it happen
you know and but once it doesn't happen
then it becomes a problem and he's gonna
say what do you got to say you know but
this team has to get better and I think
magic has to start that magic has to do
that don't pay attention to what he's
saying coach your team manage your team
and do what you got to do this team when
they won 34 games this year later on
seven up over what they did last year
that's an improvement they're gonna have
a good good you know I think summer they
got a lot of money to get a lot of
players just let's just make our
basketball team better and then we come
back to next year because you've done
what you wanted to do magic have made
this team better if you get seven games
over what you did last year you've done
what you're supposed to do so don't
worry about what everybody else say run
your basketball team I've got a few more
minutes left at the top of the hour can
you please stick around
absolutely Gary Payton is here for the
television audience you're about to get
a treat radio audience will describe it
for you when we come back and put on our
app the all-time great trash talker Gary
Payton is gonna talk trash to Chris
Brockman and we'll see how that works
out that's next here on the Rich Eisen
show for the television audience when we
come back more big three and maybe
LeBron talk but we go out the door Gary
Payton before kg joins us
[Music]
all right so Gary Payton Harris Brockman
a on the Callaway corner yeah all right
you just want to have a putting contest
for that hole right there and then talk
as much trash rock you go here because
you won't meet it got you talking about
you could play age before beauty guess
which ball you want me to I'll show you
what I write baby yeah there you go good
shot that's a good let's see let's see
if he can do it here let me see if I got
it in me I want to go a little longer no
bruh who dressed you this morning users
wear sweat pants Newton here we go okay
hold on this is what you couldn't have
read Rick that's not jumper this is
nobody in its frame this is what you
couldn't do against MJ in 96
but without a cover but was I want to
cover
that's what we talked about let me go to
make this let me go let me go
mission completed Sam Perkins called me
said this was junk oh and what did he do
what did he do baby
[Applause]
pressure bus a gray doughnut it buses a
grape ah that's a good shot take another
shot yeah I mean it's like riding a
bicycle for Gary pays just one on the
Callaway corner had a putted contest
between Brockman and Gary and the new
trash talked him and you sunk a putt at
one point Gary there was like a shot of
me just looking at you with your mouth
wide open barking at Brockman I thought
like that I was felt like I was
transported back for a second I do that
every time rich I play dominoes cars
everything that's what I do I just have
I just have fun have fun and that's
where I was raised and that was fun
brought who the man your aren't your
unmatched in the art of trash I did
think I held my own I just couldn't make
any of the pun you could well I mean
that's I did not make one just like
stomped all over thee
just fantastic did you tell cube you
thought that there was a disputed finish
to the big three did you talk you do no
idea you know I did and then I ran in
there and I got on the referee to Iran
after we method at tours locker room and
then the security had to come get look I
was upset about because you know rich
you don't in a game like that with these
players what was it it was it was it was
Mac Moody was guarding somebody and it
was a tie ballgame we had just came back
and in our league if you get fouled and
it's a 3-pointer you get a chance to try
to shoot for the three point a if you
make it it's a three and then all of a
sudden you get the ball back yeah and
you can win the game that way so we were
winning and he made it three he went up
one and we posted win by two in the game
and he made a jump shot after that and
beat us you know they beat us a 51/49 or
something like that to win the game and
I don't think that's fair for a player
to do that if you work that hard to come
back and if I wasn't a file and this
referee he's been on me all year long
anyway so it's good you know it was fun
but I'm gonna come back this year and
we're gonna be right there in the same
situation both three-headed monsters are
coming back you're the head coach
Commissioner glide yeah Clyde you know
what it's good cube appointed him
I think Clyde is very passionate you
know I looked up to Clyde playing
against Clyde and for many of years and
me and him are like this now and I think
Clyde is gonna be good for us being a
commissioner no he's gonna he's looking
out for the players just like what Ice
Cube is going to and I think it was a
great great fit for them he's coming on
the show later this week gilad with with
the coach who's taking his spot Nancy
Lieberman Nancy is gonna be a good I
think that was a great thing we're
having a woman coming in and coach and
do that and especially Nancy me and
Nancy your site too so she's gonna be a
great coach for that team to land and
get a good relationship and they're
gonna love Nancy Nancy is a basketball
player and she
competitor and she wants to win Garrett
come back this is a blast anytime rich
I'll be back I'm gonna be not gonna your
door rich let's do it all right any time
Gary Payton Anna knocking on our door in
our number two is kevin garnett to hit
on all these subjects going on in the in
the NBA with the NBA Playoffs right
around the corner that's how we're
rolling in our number two on this
program the Rich Eisen show weekdays at
noon eastern on audience